hello everyone welcome to the Laing
focused Channel and my name is Paul
today's topic is Moroccan darisha
Morocco's Arabic dialect or is it
Moroccan delecia is normally considered
to belong to the Maghrebi Arabic dialect
group which includes not only Moroccan
Arabic but also Algerian Tunisian and
Hassan eeeh Arabic Moroccan delecia is
also known as the Arabic dialect which
is the most difficult for speakers of
other dialects to understand and the
further you travel east away from
Morocco the more difficult it becomes
some Arabic speakers say that hearing
Moroccan delecia is like hearing a
different language and some Moroccans
insists that darisha is actually a
different language because it's
influenced by the Amazon still other
Moroccans insist that dead Isha is
indeed Arabic and is closely connected
with classical Arabic in the 7th century
CE II the Islamic conquest of the
Maghreb region brought both Islam and
the Arabic language to Morocco but
before that Morocco is population
consisted mostly of Berber people the
term Berber actually refers to a mosaic
people a North African ethnic group that
speaks a mosaic languages when these
amazing speakers learned Arabic the
language of the new rulers their native
music languages naturally influenced the
way they spoke Arabic and this is the
source of some of dead Asia's unique
features the Iberian Peninsula also came
under Muslim control this resulted in
significant interaction between Morocco
and Spanish and Portuguese speakers from
the nearby peninsula in the 19th century
French economic interest in Morocco
brought French influence to the country
and in 1912 Morocco was divided into
French and Spanish protectorates the
Spanish protectorate occupied a strip of
the northern coast as well as a strip of
land called Cape Juby next to the
Spanish Sahara the French protectorate
occupied all the land in between this
colonial presence had an influence on
Moroccan delecia in particular in the
form of French and Spanish loanwords
these protectorates came to an end in
1956 when Morocco gained independence
Western Sahara remained a Spanish
protectorate until 1975
when it was annexed by Morocco upon
independence Morocco's official language
became
Arabic and in 2011 amazi was also made
an official language but French
continues to be a prestige language
alongside modern Standard Arabic until
this day many Moroccans are fluent in
French especially in the major city and
it's commonly used in business and in
government and it's the main language of
university instruction this has resulted
in the continuous influence of French on
Moroccan delecia in particular academic
vocabulary and words related to modern
innovations and there's also an element
of code switching of impulsively
including French words and expressions
in Tunisia off-the-cuff currently in
Morocco about 65% of the population
speaks dead Eva as a first language
around 30% speaks in a mosaic dialect as
a first language but the vast majority
of them speak dead Eva as a second
language as well modern Standard Arabic
and French are learned at school
modern Standard Arabic is limited to
certain formal situations media and
writing
whereas dead Eva is used for daily
communication rather than modern
Standard Arabic now let's take a look at
Moroccan delecia Moroccan darisha
differs from modern Standard Arabic and
from other Arabic dialects in a number
of ways vocabulary as I mentioned before
there are many French loanwords in
Moroccan delecia for example the word
for table table which comes from French
tabla
whereas in standard Arabic it's paella
Hospital Samhita from French oppa tal
though I suspect it shares a double
etymology with Spanish because of the s
in the word in Spanish it's Hospital in
Standard Arabic it's Mustafa apartment
but MA from French apothem Oh in
Standard Arabic it's come to a lesser
extent there is also Spanish vocabulary
the word for kitchen cuisine from
Spanish Kathina in Standard Arabic it's
mutt buff week semana from Spanish
semana
in Standard Arabic it's bore some words
come from
Alma's if the word meaning how much shan
shan fabric this means how old are you
in standard arabic it's can the word
forty at
the Arabic word is shy and some words
are of Arabic origin but have changed or
are used differently
the Moroccan word for a lot is Zen this
is the equivalent of kaffir in standard
Arabic it comes from classical Arabic
Bijoux F which means a lot or without
measure the dead Asia word for who is
school this probably comes from the
classical Arabic I ashiya-kun which
means anything is or whichever is but
its meaning has evolved to mean who the
dead is a word for the number two is
zoos
whereas in Standard Arabic it is known
Jewish comes from the Arabic word zoj
meaning pair or couple pronunciation one
of the most important features of
Moroccan delecia and the one that makes
it the most difficult for speakers of
other dialects to understand is vowel
reduction short vowels are often reduced
to a schwa sound or dropped entirely
resulting in new consonant clusters and
sometimes in syllables that consists of
only consonants this is because of the
influence of a mosaic phonology on
delecia for example valid meaning
country or city in Moroccan delecia it's
pronounced bled another example get up
this is the past tense verb stem of the
verb meaning to write but in Moroccan
pronunciation it's like this till una
means here but in Morocco it's now in
all of these examples the Arabic word
has stress on the first syllable
but in the Dead Asia word the stress
moves to the final vowel and the earlier
vowel is reduced or dropped this
tendency becomes a bit more important
with multiple words and detectable this
means you write but in Morocco it's
pronounced take a super and detectable
take a supe grammar I would say that
Moroccan dead eases grammar is not
radically different from other Arabic
dialects which share a lot in common
with each other and which differ from
modern Standard Arabic in similar ways
but the influence of a mosaic grammar is
indeed obvious in a number of different
structures one example is the lack of a
dual form Indonesia in standard arabic
there are singular plural and dual
forms dual being used when there are two
of something in Standard Arabic we have
Peter Byrne
but Indonesia it's juice ketubah another
example is the passive form in Moroccan
delecia in Standard Arabic the passive
is formed by changing the vowels of the
verb katha balki Java means he wrote the
book could you break it up in Moroccan
delecia you formed the passive by simply
inserting two before an active verb
sibling said means he wrote the book and
said it means the book was written
another example is a pattern of forming
abstract nouns from other nouns by
prefixing top and adding to as a suffix
cadet means liar and tech dead means
habitual lying this same pattern is
found in a mazayef this particular word
is not used in all local dialects but
there are lots of other similarly formed
words often related to occupations also
the reflexive Indonesia directly mirrors
the AMA Z reflexive a you Jeffress of
Lemuria this means I you saw himself in
the mirror the way himself is expressed
literally means his head in Standard
Arabic the sentence would be that a a a
you Agnetha in Mirat in Standard Arabic
a different word nufs is used instead of
thus one extra thing to notice here is
that the Standard Arabic sentence is VSO
the verb comes at the beginning but the
daily just sentence is SVO with the
subject before the verb now let's look
at a few Moroccan darisha sentences and
break them down this sentence means I
ride the bus to school every day in the
kebab is andressa cool and hard word for
words I ride the bus the school every
day in Standard Arabic it would be a
novel hostile al in Madras aku Leone
first notice that the Standard Arabic
sentence has a subject pronoun while the
deadly just sentence doesn't actually
it's optional and standard arabic as
well so with that optional pronoun aside
notice that the first word of the
sentence is different the Moroccan word
has a prefix cat to indicate present
tense while the Standard Arabic sentence
does not
also the standard Arabic word has the
first person singular prefix ah
while the Moroccan word has no in
Standard Arabic the prefix nut would
indicate first person plural you may
have also noticed that the vowel
patterns of these two words are
different
next notice this word tobey's which
comes from the French word Auto boosts
the Standard Arabic word is a Fela both
before tobey's and before the next word
madrasah we see the definite article in
Standard Arabic it's al but Indonesia
it's reduced to Allah in madrasah notice
that the vowel pattern and stress are
different with the Dead Isha word losing
its first vowel or it becomes a very
short schwa sound next we see Kandahar
and in Standard Arabic we see Kulu young
Mahad and young are both Standard Arabic
words and both exist Indonesia with
slightly different pronunciation this is
simply a matter of dialectal word choice
you could also say Coulomb in Moroccan
delecia another sentence this means I
don't have any cats but I have nine fish
manda seems with a cane and it says
loses word for word it's not I have
negative any cat but I have nine of fish
in Standard Arabic it would be lazy
ledee you could not like in ledee a
decide to a smirk your first impression
might be that these two sentences are
quite different
first the way of expressing the negative
is different and E is actually not a
verb but a preposition meaning with plus
the pronominal suffix E meaning me in
standard Arabic you make this sentence
negative using leisa while in moroccan
delecia you make it negative by
prefixing math and suffixing [ __ ] this
is a double negative like in French no
plus pas this is not exclusively
Moroccan and a similar form is used
generally in North African dialects and
sometimes in Palestinian as well she
means thing but is used with the
negative to mean any or anything the
Standard Arabic equivalent is a yeah
next we see that the word for cat is
different mush is the dead Isha word for
cat and was borrowed from amazeen the
word for nine is DISA
which is similar to the standard Arabic
word there's also another word for nine
which is often used in Morocco it's owed
this depends on where you are in Morocco
next Indonesia we see DL meaning of this
is not present in Standard Arabic then
we have the word who Ted which is the
dead easy word for fish in Standard
Arabic and in most other dialects it
would be s Mac or something similar
another sentence
what should we see cos Duma this means
do you want a glass of water
word for word it's question marker you
want glass of the water in Standard
Arabic it would be hell to read Kazan
minima the first word here
Wesch is used as a marker for yes-or-no
questions in standard arabic hal or AK
are used the next word the he T is
actually the past tense form of a verb
meaning to like but in the past tense
form like this it's similar to would
like in the present tense
it means like this form with the suffix
T is the second person singular form for
both masculine and feminine in Standard
Arabic there are separate forms for
masculine singular and feminine singular
but in Moroccan delecia there is no
difference in the Standard Arabic
sentence we see a different word to read
which is in the regular present tense
form this is the second person singular
masculine and there's a different
feminine form to Rodina or Tori Dean
next we see the phrase for glass of
water
the main difference here lies in the
prepositions Standard Arabic uses min
which means from and delecia uses the
which I suspect comes from the French
preposition do and one more sentence
this sentence means
yesterday we ate chicken but today we'll
eat beef we better clean it judge with a
cumin igloo boogity word for word it's
yesterday we ate chicken but today
future marker we eat beef and in
Standard Arabic Alberta Canada Josh will
a connealy ohms and a Coulomb al-bakr
first we see basically the same words
meaning yesterday but Indonesia the
definite article is reduced and the
final vowel is missing there's another
word for yesterday in Standard Arabic
alums which is perhaps more common but
this one Alberta
is also Standard Arabic next we see that
standard Arabic and dead Isha have very
different forms of the same verb notice
that the root letters culluh are the
same but the dead Isha word is missing
the first root letter Alif and the vowel
patterns are very different yet both of
these are the first-person plural past
tense form of the verb to eat here we
see why Lacan is the same except that
the vowels are shortened Indonesia and
here we have Illume which is al yom in
standard arabic remember that in a
previous sentence we saw nod instead of
um--
both are possible even though Nihad
tends to be common next we see the
future tense in standard Arabic the
future tense is formed by adding the
prefix sad to the present tense form or
alternatively another pre verb sulfa is
used but in Moroccan delecia you add the
pre verb Hadi to the present tense form
notice again that the present tense form
has the prefix kha' and Nakuru this is
equivalent to Nakul in Standard Arabic
but Indonesia the vowel here is
shortened and we add a suffix ooh to
indicate that this is first-person
plural not first-person singular
since both of them have the prefix nut
Indonesia the first person singular
resembles the first person plural in
standard Arabic so this vowel suffix is
added to indicate plural as you can see
Moroccan delecia differs quite a lot
from Standard Arabic but is it different
enough to be considered a different
language well that's debatable
all Arabic dialects differ from Standard
Arabic in ways similar to those seen in
this video the exact words and
constructions aren't the same but the
same types of differences are prominent
in most dialects as Arabic expanded into
new lands and was adopted by speakers of
other languages well over 1200 years ago
new Arabic speakers in each community
developed their own variety of Arabic
that was influenced by their previous
native language so while Moroccan Arabic
shows the influence of a mosaic
languages Egyptian Arabic shows the
influence of the Coptic language and the
dialects of the Levant region show the
influence of Aramaic etc from my point
of view the one thing that makes
Moroccan Arabic less intelligible for
speakers of other dialects is its
phonology specifically its stress and
the
action of vowels but it seems to me that
this problem can be overcome through
exposure and by the Moroccan speaker
slowing down a little bit for an English
speaker
maybe it's comparable to say rural
Scottish English spoken very quickly on
first listen it may sound to you like a
different language but if they slow down
for you you might be able to understand
it makes sense of all those different
vowel sounds and assuming both of us
have been to school and are literate we
can adjust our speech a little bit to
make it more like a book and speakers of
Moroccan dead Eva can do the same thing
by including some elements of Standard
Arabic into their speech or by using
some elements of Syrian and Egyptian
dialects be sure to follow Lange focus
on Facebook Twitter and Instagram and
once again thank you to all of my
amazing patreon supporters especially
these ones right here on the screen
they are my top tier patreon supporters
thank you to them
and to everyone thank you for watching
and have a nice day
[Music]
[Music]